I could just imagine two couples wearing
like they like film each other having
the best sex ever and they're just
reliving that yeah
honey what's wrong you uh you haven't
put on your Apple Vision today
welcome back to a my third is ruined
welcome back to another episode of the
trash taste podcast I'm Connor featuring
The Boys Joey and Khan uh hi it's pretty
hot here too what are you why are you
doing I don't know Japanese summer yeah
that's my thing Japanese summer is uh
coming and uh it's here okay it is it's
gross it's not as bad right now it's
just humid that's all that's not bad
that's the bad part of town like yeah I
mean like I just came back from America
uh came just came back from I guess the
the West Coast again once again because
I I figured out this uh yeah I was like
I remember at the start of this year I
said to myself I'm going to travel less
to America the next year and I think uh
I figured it out now I'm traveling to
America now
four months five months in a row I think
wait wait wait wait wait
I am
we went in when did we go to Hawaii
again
March yeah uh went in April what'd you
get for April I swear we went in April
right oh no we went to Australia Okay no
Okay [__] wait did I just did I just
mistake America for a straw oh my god oh
I'm gonna I'm sorry just declared war in
Australia I've been to America a bunch I
don't know I went in February yeah
I'm going to June I'm the only real
hater I've only been once well Joey to
be fair you uh I would be in the same
position where else yeah I would be in
the same position because uh
you know every time you go to America
you get to stop some questions and yeah
you get treated like uh terrorists I I
get treated like an animal yeah so no
thank you for me but you know what I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna say something
controversial I'm gonna say something
controversial go on then I enjoyed my
trip in America this time
we we everyone knows we like America we
like America we're just in there is for
America yeah so this time I was like I
guess I guess it was like the
first time in a while when I've where
I've been to America purely just for a
holiday no working
no collabing with YouTube YouTubers no
kind of like no way no convention to go
to I just went to America chilled out
with some friends and uh yeah went to
Napa Valley and oh that's why okay no no
actually actually at we we you know the
mystery has been solved
even before Napa Valley you know it's uh
we uh went to uh Lake Tahoe uh which is
kind of like near San Francisco I see so
many of these places in movies I just
assume that they're like you know I look
like Tahoe Lake Tahoe have you been to
Lake Tahoe I've been to Lake Tahoe yeah
it's a Lake Tahoe it's a lake called
Tahoe yeah why is it always mentioned
what's so special about it I have no
idea it's just uh it's just a nice area
it's very I didn't understand what uh
you know America core is until I went to
a place like Lake Tahoe and I'm like oh
this is like American tourism just like
in a nutshell it's like just like a nice
Scenic Lake and then there's like a
little touristy town with little
Trinkets and souvenirs it's what
Japanese people Envision the perfect
American holidays yeah I feel yeah it is
the perfect American holiday and going
to Lake Tahoe after spending so much
time in Japan this is uh this is uh This
is Gonna this is gonna sound like a joke
but it's not I realized I kind of uh
kind of missed the freedom you get in
America he's been indoctrinated
what do you mean we lost a fellow
brother I don't know because like
sometimes you go on a holiday in Japan
you want to do like an activity or
something right and it's just like you
have to phone ahead make sure everyone
has the right equipment make sure
everything is booked out you go in the
at the right time Stone if you missed
that time slot and then it was just nice
being in somewhere like Lake Tahoe and
just waking up and being like what do we
feel like doing today oh let's rent a
boat oh do we have to book out anything
so we didn't know if we haven't booked
out book out a boat or something like
that so we went for lunch somewhere and
then we just saw that there was a boat
rental place like right next to the
lunch place we were going to and we were
just like let's just ask if we could you
know maybe book out a boat maybe today
or tomorrow uh so we go to the place and
they're just like yeah when you need a
boat just uh and other uniquely Japan
problems this is uh this is a very Japan
problem and and I was like you need a
license and they're like nope do you
need a time slot and they were like when
do you think you're gonna be back and we
can uh just get you uh do you if if you
can't drive a boat we can get you a
captain no worries uh that is like the
mentality I love that Japan does not
have like the [__] it mentality yeah
it's just being like yeah [__] it
cigarettes [__] it I'm like uh can we
like bring like fishing rods or can we
have like other stuff on the boat and
they're like yeah you can uh you can do
you know water ski if you want you can
do like uh all these other activities
huh I did not water skiing that day
because the the uh the water was [__]
freezing funnily enough it was it was so
pretty like there were still places near
Lake Tahoe where you can go skiing and
this was like in June so I was like what
is this weather right now this is very
confusing but I did go uh the word
[__] uh fly fishing
okay for the first time which I've been
I I've realized now I've done a lot of
different kinds of fishing and before
like two years ago I'd never fished in
my life I was like all fishing is kind
of the same right which
uh
all fishing the same you are just you
just put the rod in the water wait for
the bite and then you just reel it in I
played in a fishing minigame yeah I
thought I thought all fishing was
basically the fishing mini game in every
video game you've ever played uh and the
first exhibition experience was
basically just that it was basically
you're on a lake you just put out the
line wait for the fish to buy and the
bite feels exactly like
it does in a video game if you feel the
vibration and then you just like start
you see that press a prompt you see the
press a prompt and then you just start
reeling it in and and then we had the
fishing trip with geeks plus and that
was like fishing easy mode yeah right
yeah we've briefly talked about this but
we've we're like in a river and then
they literally threw the fish in this
River for us to catch they said this
there is this many fish here's the
tutorial yeah I love how at that time to
everyone everyone saw that yeah they
didn't even make it subtle and we all
just kind of silently agree with like
let's just pretend we didn't see that
but it's like just for I'll say Just
Around enjoyment
[__] see that yeah and the funny
thing is they even like they even gave
us like an SSR catch because there was
one golden fish there was one there was
there was in the sea of like gray fish
there was one golden fish that they put
in the bucket which was the SSR cap that
was Five Points which was Five Points uh
and so so um we decided to do fly
fishing in uh Lake Tahoe or near Lake
Tahoe and I was like I've done fishing
before how hard could this be you know
I've I've had I've had some fishing
experience uh I didn't so it kind of
confused me when we decided to do fly
fishing that there was like an hour-long
kind of like tutorial stage I was like
what are we doing for an hour wait do
you wanna do you want to explain fly
fishing for people who don't know what
it is I still don't know what the
technical definition is of fly fishing
but if you've ever seen in a movie or a
TV show where someone's fishing and
they're doing this a lot
it like spins or does like something to
catch the the attention of the fish
right uh that's actually not so the
reason the reason something else maybe
because uh basically what I always
thought was uh fly fishing is the one
where you see people just like whipping
the line around before they throw it in
and that's because that's basically to
give you control over exactly where you
threw where you throw the law in right
so you can control the the reason I've
realized why we needed an hour
um an hour long kind of like session
teaching us how to properly throw the
law is because it is actually quite hard
to keep control of uh your key control
of the length the exact length and the
direction uh and making sure because if
you throw it you need to throw it so
it's like the law uh and the line is
completely straight right which is a lot
and so you have to get like the timing
exactly right when you're kind of like
whipping it like back and forth back and
forth you let a little bit more go and
then depending on how much of the line
you let go which is the length of the
line you're trying to throw the timing
is a bit different because it's almost
like if you miss time it then the uh the
QuickTime event yeah it is it is it is
exactly a quick Time Event and you have
to go through this before even getting
your line into the river right right if
you [__] it up then you've already
you've like you've already [__] up
basically because there's you know
there's so many things that can go wrong
maybe whip it too hard and then the line
goes into the water before you actually
throw the line in because you're meant
to throw it in as softly as possible so
let's mentioned just like kind of like
um it's kind of like meant to be like a
leaf or something or like like an insect
just dropping off and just like falling
to the river but if you like [__]
whip it in the water that's obviously
going to scare this scare the fish all
right
um so it's uh this is like fishing with
the uh Dark Souls patch like put in
there's a lot more it sounds like a
multi-faced boss fight yeah it is it is
a multi-faced boss fight because on top
of that uh all the fishing I'm used to
is that when the line's in you just wait
right you don't have to do anything and
you wait for the pool yeah and we're fly
fishing
uh the hook that we're given was like
way smaller than what it usually is uh
so you have to like Eagle Eye your Eagle
Eye like the line on the water and as
soon as you see any kind of movement at
all you gotta [__] you just gotta
[__] pull up yeah right you you
actually have to like you actually have
to like be attentive because uh how we
how it was explained to us is like the
trouts obviously they don't want to
waste calories eating something right so
they're not gonna like swim up and like
bite it what's gonna happen is you're
gonna drop the line they're gonna see
something that looks a bit nice and
they're gonna waste the least amount of
calories as possible we're just giving
it a nibble and they're just gonna let
go because again why are the Trout's so
concerned about calories like what are
they what are they bulking like okay
well well if they're survival right yeah
if they expend more calories to eat
something than it is then the calories
that they're eating you're right and
then then then they're gonna die yeah
gonna die okay yeah yeah so basically
you you have like a 0.5 second chance so
as soon as you see something you just
gotta [__] just yeah you have to it's
it is like it is like that fishing
minigame where you you you think you see
you think you feel something and as soon
as you think you feel or see something
you just gotta like press up you just
you just gotta press a yeah and ninety
percent of the time you uh you didn't
feel anything or you didn't see anything
it was just the war the movement of the
water and then on top of that which is
actually the part of that this is the
part that I like the most right because
fly fishing uh you don't reel it in
right you pull it in okay so you so
because the hook is a lot smaller than a
lot of other uh fishing I'm used to
um there's a chance that the trout could
just get away yeah and the trout could
uh actually free himself uh so you you
you do the yank to actually like set the
hook into the drought yeah yeah
um so that's that's why you have to yank
it really hard and once it's set
you gotta fight it right so you you
that's that's actually you you have to
you stamina ball pop song
the stamina bar pops up right the
stamina box is a big one the standard
ball pops up and what happens is uh so
there's there's different things you
have to do right so you stagger the fish
you basically have to stagger the fish
you have to wear it down so you don't
okay so here's the thing
so you have to like angle Your Rod so
it's like the perfect angle where it's
like just a little bit bent right so
it's kind of like that so you so it's it
gives like resistance towards the fish
so if they're swimming like away you
have to angle it so it's not too like so
it's not too angry otherwise the line's
gonna snap but that's not too easy it's
like it's a [__] Speed Run it's like
so this is the angle perfect movement
right here explain to us it needs to be
angle perfect so if they're swimming
away you need to angle it so it's the
perfect amount of resistance so they are
still like spending energy but not
enough that the line snaps but what
happens if the fish swims towards you
well that's when you actually start
reeling it in and you reel it in by hand
you start ringing it by hand so it's
kind of like it is literally the stamina
bar and you have to like angle your
controller so so that it's like perfect
it's the perfect angle it is it I guess
it's rooted in reality yeah it
and uh I gotta say it is [__]
addictive holy [__] yeah I think my
little brother does it all the time yeah
I think he's like hooked on it yeah I I
think I I did it once and it's it's got
like the perfect gameplay Loop of just
like one more time just just
uh with this one we uh we we have to put
them back because uh otherwise you uh
normally we we are under supervision
normally you need a fishing license and
uh you have them can only uh fish a
certain amount so you don't overfish the
lake or whatever so this one we're under
supervision so we didn't need a fishing
license and we put all the trouts back
um but yeah it was it was [__] I think I
get fishing now like after that after
like the Japan trip I was like this is a
this is pretty boring you know uh with
the fish just come to you and you're
like okay it's only eating them isn't
fun as well yeah eating them is fun oh
yes the cycle of life but yeah fly
fishing is the fishing minigame uh for
gamers of course it is for gamers it is
addicting and it's most of the time it's
like you get an hour of just boredom of
just like throwing it in and then like
the adrenaline rush of like when you're
actually fighting the fish and like
making like making sure like I made this
fish my [__] man I showed him who's
boss he knows you know those and then
you catch it and you're like all right
that was that was actually that was
right that was that was [__] hype
actually I think of all the fishing I've
done which is two
um ice fishing was my least favorite oh
what's ice fishing like I mean I've done
that too it's just not fun I mean it
depends how much did you catch I caught
like seven but what were the size of the
fish you were catching like that be yeah
they're like this yeah they're tiny well
I mean there's no fish I know I know
larger that could survive though it's
like the most if if that's like the
accurate mini game yeah ice fishing is
the like Cookie Clicker yeah it's the
idol fishing it's like you don't really
do much you just I might want to keep
tapping it and and although these old
men were trolling me uh and they were
they were trying to make me as cold as
possible because they knew I was
unprepared and they were [__] with me
but they also I'm completely unrelated
they kept calling each other skip it
yeah like perfect yeah they've been
calling each other hey this guy's a
pervert I'm like I'm in the same tennis
yeah I'm uncomfortable
um yeah but that was just like
and then you'd catch something you're
like oh great the world's smallest fish
I mean I thought it was really fun
because I didn't joining across Japan I
thought it was super fun because you
guys all had your own like nice private
yeah we were in like a tent together and
like it was Pete and Chris versus me and
natsky and it was only fun because we
[__] destroyed Pete and Chris yeah
we're literally sitting right next to us
like this distance apart own hole to
fish through and we were just fishing
all this I could see that I could see
the joy in it if you were in a nice tent
and you had like a heater yeah you need
some beers yeah and just chilling with
the boys yeah yeah I get it but as like
uh the actual fishing aspect I was just
like it's not that high so boring yeah
yeah for sure it's like there's I
realize different types of fishing are
good for different types of let's say
environments I've been ocean fishing as
well I [__] despise those [__] that
was actually actually ocean fishing was
the worst one yeah ocean fishing was
like the combination of ever like all of
the most boring parts of fishing with
just an unpleasant experience yeah I've
only I've never done it I've only seen
like footage of people doing it looks
like hectic but in the most not fun way
yeah yeah yeah it's just like you oh
you're you're you the adrenaline is
rushing through your body but you're not
catching anything
yeah honestly fly fishing has been my
favorite so far
in terms of just I I think I think I'm
like next time I get an opportunity I'm
definitely gonna try it again uh and uh
[__] didus destroyed everyone it's
the Mainer in him I don't like I I
caught three fish uh on average like in
our group people call like two or three
fish cynical one uh dinos like caught
nine and then he stopped early because
he was like I think I'm done
I've maxed out yeah he stopped like half
now before everyone else did and then
there's me like half an hour after our
time has run out to be like come on just
one more I just wanted to throw one more
line it's this line This is the line
he's a kid who finishes the test 30
minutes
and then someone stands up 30 minutes in
yeah to our exam you're like what's like
this
no [__]
yeah this episode is sponsored by
expressvpn watching Netflix without
using expressvpn it's like going to the
arcade but only playing one game what
that sounds like an absolute waste why
would you ruin your potential like that
exactly well slander aside of my
character gun luckily for expressvpn you
can access all of the different content
libraries that are outside of your own
country on services such as Netflix you
can control where you want Netflix or
other streaming websites to think you're
located for example I wanted to watch a
particular show that was only available
on the US Netflix but I live in Japan
how do I watch it I flick on expressvpn
turn it over to the US and form
everything in us Netflix open for me too
soon plus you can stream in HD with zero
buffering and it's compatible on all of
your devices I'm talking phones laptops
media consoles Smart TVs and a whole lot
more and you can gain access to
thousands of new shows which also works
with other streaming services such as
BBC iPlayer YouTube and more gentlemen
wow I am so glad that I left that
recording session to come home and
install expressvpn because it was so
easy so be smart and stop paying full
price for streaming services and only
getting access to a fraction of their
content get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com trash taste don't forget
to use our Link at
expressvpn.com trash taste to get an
extra three months for Xbox VPN for free
but I guess I also realize now
um I definitely do not enjoy driving I
am I am not a oh really I am not a
driver like I I thought you know this
would this would be the big test because
me driving in America I had to like
Drive
until Lake Tahoe which was a Pleasant
uh like four hours [__] hell yeah I
actually saw that's an average average
foreign
yeah but like I mean Lake Tahoe was a
very very beautiful area that kind of
area is very beautiful and you know I
kind of like wait what car did you run
uh I've rented an SUV not a not a
[__] Jeep or whatever yeah it wasn't
a massive Jeep just just a normal SUV
you got like a nice I just feel like
America I get bit kind of big car
culture a little bit because I'm like
yeah it feels nice you got the big room
yeah music blaring AC do you know what I
got what country music as soon as we got
to the Lake Tahoe as soon as we got to
like the like the Lake Tahoe area the
nature like [__] Nature Valley
everywhere and uh yeah uh dinos was like
put on some country music I'm like that
is I'm not [__] putting on country
music and he was like give me give me
the phone and he put it on and uh you
know started off um
started off with the classics Country
Road and then started putting on some
other stuff I've never heard of and I'm
like
[__] no I can't get this now [__] I'm
open to all sorts of music country is
one that I just can't country under any
other circumstance I'm like no get the
[__] out of here but driving driving on
actual country roads in America I'm like
okay actually kind of a Vibe actually
okay so why didn't you like driving then
stressful
it's maybe it's like but you're like out
in the middle of nowhere what's there to
be stressed about I get if you're in
like the middle of the city and there's
traffic a roundabouts you just go
straight up it's look it's it's
stressful because okay I think this is
like my I think this is like an ADHD
thing but I just feel like there are I
might be it's it's the thought of being
in a situation where if I [__] up I die
right
what do you mean why is that funny wait
why is that funny
there's a lot of things that could apply
to yeah but like and then that's half
the things you do in life right no okay
no when you're driving it's like riding
a bicycle
what no you're never you're barely ever
going fast enough on the bicycle to
Warrant okay if I [__] up there's a big
possibility I could die most of the time
if you're on a bicycle uh you the worst
that could happen is that you fall over
or something right yeah
no no okay okay when you cross the roads
like if I just stop right now when a car
hits me I could die no no when you cross
the road that is not comparable to
driving a car when you ride the bike
there's an amount of risk that you take
on daily as a human being and driving
probably gives you a little bit more
rooms yes and driving the thing about
driving it is it is a constant you have
to be like at least for me you have to
be mentally just on yeah mentally click
because if you can't just like I would
hope so yeah yeah you can't just like I
guess just zone out when you're driving
uh completely obviously hopefully uh
otherwise you put yourself and all your
passengers at risk so for me I just like
being mentally on and being aware of my
mirrors and just being aware that you
know I'm constantly following the road
following the road rules even on like an
empty roads uh it's actually especially
on a country road because country roads
are normally a bit more windier a bit
more control needed so I'm like it's
just a lot of time where I need to be
mentally on for a very long period of
time are you the kind of person that
hates it when someone is talking to you
while you're driving uh like you can't
concentrate like you can't hold a
conversation while you're driving no I
would rather someone talk to me but as
as long as I don't have to talk back
which is what I mean which is which is
which is why me and said well that's not
quite a conversation okay it's like like
you just gone she's like
there's literally no difference to you
just listening to a podcast at that
point
actually yeah yeah it's not a live
podcast in your car which is why I very
much enjoy uh driving with Sydney
because she can like just she can talk
my ear off and I'm like that's that's
interesting that's interesting and it's
just that's just like that's great honey
but they're not listening yeah I'm
actually that's the thing I am actually
listening it's it's keeping me attentive
and aware but not enough where I need to
like put thoughts into my like a
conversation back and everything like
that that's like my perfect drive you
know but it's just yeah it's just to me
I don't know if this is a me thing it's
just very mentally taxing to be that
switched on for that long amount of time
even if it's a very beautiful area I
mean four hours is a long drive bro like
yeah I mean Americans make it look easy
but I don't know everyone else that's a
long [__] drive yeah I don't I don't
know how I don't know how Americans do
it but yeah me driving I realize yeah I
get like there's always this small
anxiety in in me I don't know know this
is me thing I'm I'm saying this not to
you guys I'm saying this to you guys to
be like this there must be someone out
there like me right there definitely is
yeah yeah because I think there's you
know we joke about Americans love
driving and doing it but I think I've
met a fair amount of Americans you're
like I just wish I didn't have to drive
yeah oh Aki hates it yeah yeah she's
like I have to because otherwise I can't
[__] get anywhere yeah I I would
under any other circumstance uh give me
the passage give me the passenger seat
every time if if I have the choice of
being a passenger or getting the freedom
to drive myself I will choose being a
passenger uh passenger every single time
um because yeah it's just I there's this
anxiety feeling that I can never get rid
of no matter what when I'm driving and
that's just that feeling of having to be
mentally switched on uh no matter what
the situation music helps me use it
helps you drive yeah yeah same country
music yeah no
I mean if it's the only thing available
I'll listen to it you know next time if
we ever go to an America trip where we
go out to the Wilderness I swear to God
I swear to God Try It Out Try It Out uh
you might you might you might discover
something about yourself because I
thought I've had a couple of bangers but
like I don't think I could sit for like
an entire four-hour road trip just
listening it's it's it's a it's about
the vibe you know sometimes sometimes
it's like drifting and eurobe you know
yeah sometimes you just find a situation
or an environment where you put on the
right track and then suddenly everything
just clicks together you know I feel
like if everyone gets nervous when
you're driving in Europe it comes on
it's like oh [__] not an imitation is it
getting faster or is it just me yeah
you know sometimes yeah yeah I mean
that's issue with like every piece of
music genre you know sometimes you'll
find the perfect music genre for the
perfect Vibe and even if you're not a
fan of that genre you kind of like [__]
with it at that particular moment in
time um I'm sure there are other moments
that I'm like kind of like blanking on
right now but yeah country music on
country roads Sun who knew actually
[__] works that is true like
depending on what I'm listening to while
I'm driving my mood is completely
different if I'm I I never put on like
punk music when I'm driving yeah because
I just get so angry yeah like every
small tiny little thing like this guy
just like slightly deviated into my lane
I'm just like
[__] you do you know you know what uh do
you know what music genre I've kind of
like fallen out of
kind of I don't know if it's like
falling out is the right word but just
Lo-Fi what is the what is the what is
the right mood or what is the right
situation to ever put like it's it's
modern day elevator music it is it's
just music yeah yeah you know people
people just it's it's good background
noise that I think everyone is agreeable
on and that it's not annoying it's good
it's good homework music if you're just
like sitting at your desk and you just
need some kind of noise in the
background yeah like it's just like
ambient music like it's just it's just
noise in the background it's just the
most inoffensive I I get Lo-Fi because
it's the most inoffensive kind of music
you can put no one's going to complain
about Lo-Fi except for me right now but
I've somehow found a way to accept it
Okay the reason is okay the reason is
every time like me and Cindy have people
over to uh to our house oh yeah Sydney
puts Lo-Fi on and and it's it's it's
happened enough times now where I'm like
Sydney why are you putting this on yeah
and I'm and she's just like oh she's
who's going to complain about Lo-Fi and
I'm Sydney
I am could you do this every single time
the conversation feel like you're stale
yeah I feel like it's like I'm bored
yeah exactly right cut that [__] off put
on some country right now I'm just like
Sydney why I hope thing on me yeah
Sydney why uh why are you being scared
right now I'm lying she's like what are
you talking about and I'm like why are
you being so scared to put on your own
Taste of Music in music yeah you know
what I mean because like if you go
around a house and people put Lo-Fi on
what I think is why are you scared to
show me your actual music taste yeah
true why are you not putting on your
actual Spotify playlist here come on
he's gonna get judged yeah yeah don't be
a [__] all right all right do you guys
have a music playlist to put on when
there are people around or do you just
have I play the same five songs for
everything
I actually realized recently uh because
I was also the guy where I'm just like I
don't want to [__] scare the hoes
like showing all these like weird people
oh
all right with all the weird [__] that I
listened to privately so yeah yeah so I
was always the dude where I'm just like
Everyone likes Lo-Fi I'll just put on
some Lo-Fi yeah but now I'm just getting
to the point where I've listened to so
much Lo-Fi and I've listened to so much
Lo-Fi in YouTube videos where I'm like
every time I put it on I just feel like
I'm watching a YouTube essay
I just get into YouTube like this is
kind of boring I found out though one
playlist that works every time is an 80s
playlist yeah yeah 80s music like you
put on some [__] Michael Jackson you
put on some like you know classic like
80s rock 80s like disco stuff like you
know some Earth Wind and Fire yeah
Banger everyone everyone enjoys that
yeah because the thing I realized is
um you know in terms of like you know
sitting the right the right move for
like a house party or a house Gathering
or something you put on Lo-Fi No One's
Gonna complain about it but the music
isn't gonna bring anything for the vibe
exactly it's not gonna do anything it's
just it's just a silence filler yeah
that's it uh and you know sometimes
sometimes you're feeling you're feeling
getting brave enough to actually put on
your you know your real your real
Spotify playlists I I I've noticed
Connor you're an exception because
you're the beeps and boops guys for the
same thing normally what I've noticed
people have like two levels they have
their surface level Spotify playlist and
then they have their this is the [__] I
listen to in private and No One's Gonna
know what this playlist is
because I realized I I realized
unintentionally I have those playlists
as well when I've had when I've hosted
enough parties where I'm like I wanna I
wanna put on things that is my taste but
at least are things that I think people
will enjoy you know you know that's one
thing I hate about like Discord is that
like if you're listening to Spotify on
your computer on your Discord it says
like you know blah blah is playing
Spotify and then if you go over to it
you can see what song they're listening
to and I've had so many instances where
I'm just like chilling out listening to
my real playlist yeah um and I've had
people just message me like what the
[__] are you listening to what is this
[__] and I'm like stop judging me get
out of my life this is me time right now
stay out of it don't judge I've never
felt the need for another playlist I'm
like who doesn't want to listen to Daft
Punk
conestants
no in terms of you can play it in any
situation people will be like yes
because you're like Tame Impala like
who's gonna listen to Life one of those
songs be like God I can't stand this I'm
like no that Everyone likes the sound of
it exactly the background I pick beeps
and boobs I know what sounds good in a
background yeah yeah because like there
he kind of has five songs that he uses
for every single occasion no matter what
it is yeah yeah I mean you know Janelle
was like what was really fun actually
was uh picking
picking my wedding song playlist that
was actually the most fun I've ever had
like making a playlist uh because I
don't know
okay that wasn't part of the playlist
that was something that just kind of
like clicked into place I think uh it's
good it's good so it's so good it's so
gone Sydney yeah yeah I mean I mean you
know it's I I think if that didn't get
meme to [__]
it'd be a very powerful thing it is a
very powerful piece and uh we decided on
that before it became a big meme I guess
yeah yeah even before it became a big
meme so it I mean it is a very powerful
piece I still remember when that song
came on I've never done I've never seen
because I was sitting next to the Moon
all the time I've never seen anyone do
like the slow turn
because I was just like I know the song
mood I was like yeah me too and then the
chorus you know comes on like the
singing and we both just
[Music]
I think I think that was like a great
song to pick regardless of like the meme
status yeah I mean we picked it for us
we didn't pick it for no that's great
well you know it's uh I can understand
why there was a wide range of emotional
responses to it but you know I've
noticed this that you know this is just
a thing with modern culture in general
sometimes where there's not only just a
piece of music but just a scene from a
movie or TV show that you know when it
first airs is very hard hitting and is
one of like the most culturally let's
say culturally impactful
scenes that have come out
um that's going to get memed on to the
point where you don't you start to not
take it seriously anymore you don't have
that same emotional response you
originally did when you first saw that
thing that was me with unravel bro like
oh my god dude that I hate the internet
for ruining that song for me I cannot
listen to that song anymore when I first
watched her Google I was like damn TK
[__] Banger track amazing track
perfectly sets the time for toe Google
now every time I hear the chorus I'm
just like I just love it you could you
could hand me a like a picture of a
white background of like a blob slightly
bent at the top to the right and I think
I would immediately recognize yeah I
wouldn't even need to see kaneki's
outline you just show me a black line
tilting slightly at the top and I play
that song and I'd be like I know this
man do you know the one General one
scene I despise the fact that has been
ruined now because I it's it's one of my
favorite scenes but it is the one piece
is real what God damn it when when God
when Whitebeard said it it's such such
it's so powerful it's so powerful and
now and now it's been forever ruins now
it's been forever ruins you know every
time just can we get much higher
every iconic scene that means it's a
good if it gets memed that means it's a
good scene yeah yeah that means it
stayed in the in the in the brains of
people right yeah but now every [__]
Breaking Bad scene is still mean to this
day but here's have you ever like
re-watched not like watch the first time
I've rewatched a scene that you know has
hit you originally uh but has been
reinterpreted with like meme culture uh
and you just can't take it seriously
anymore because I'm afraid to re-watch
one piece because that scene was like so
impactful for me and now I know that
when that scene comes along I cannot see
that scene without seeing whitebeard's
clock right there like right there it's
just right there it just just his fat
[__] [__] and he says it and I'm like
[__] [__] I feel I'm gonna have that if
I ever rewatch Dragon Ball I'm gonna
have that exact same experience
it's the first time he turns Ultra
Instinct and it's a powerful scene in
the show but now I can't I can't see
that scene anymore we're just thinking
of could you repeat that
[__] stupid I had I had that exact
same thing I'm I think I've talked about
the song trash days before but the first
time I watched invincible
uh because I'd seen so many [__]
memes about it right like it was mean to
[__] yeah yeah yeah yeah the mark one
and like you know pretty much all the
scenes from the last episode and I was
like all right fine you know these memes
have intrigued me I'm gonna and you know
you boys have been saying how good it
was so I'll give it a watch and I
watched it and I got to that last
episode and you know the scenes of the
[__] think Mark think like that scene
came up and I'm like it's actually think
Mark it's not a second thing okay
whatever that's the Mandela effect
that's the Mandela effect right there
but I got to that scene and I'm like
okay I understand this is a very
powerful scene right yeah but it's just
been ruined for me because of all the
memes and I hate that one of the shows
like the boys the boys are so many memes
oh yeah homelander oh yeah yeah they're
perfect
reaction images are like all over the
phone yeah exactly
um yeah I'm wondering because I haven't
re-watched Breaking Bad since it's like
re-emergence of memes I wonder what it
would be like re-experiencing Breaking
Bad now I've watched it like a year ago
and it's it's still holds up
you should know how good it is by the
amount it still gets maimed but that's
the thing I should tell you how [__]
good but see this is the problem I'm
just satisfied with the memes now
like I'm just like I it's like I I love
all these memes even if I've never seen
the show and it's just great like I I'm
just satisfied with the memes I don't
have to watch this is insane that it's
still being memed it as much as it is
yeah this isn't like this in meme in
meme history we've never had something
mean this hard yeah like it's it's so
true yeah I that [__] image of Walter
like they change all the time but the
one now where it's Walter and the car
screaming no yeah
I saw one where it was a cyberpunk post
and they were like and the one of the
links was like CP and it was like it was
the reaction someone quote retreated it
with Walter screaming no don't
abbreviate soap Hunter CP no don't
that's so good there's so many [__]
good memes
no just so many good [__] Breaking
Bad memes they're so good yeah this
episode of trash taste is sponsored by
cash app boys do you know what I love
what do you love the feeling of leveling
up hell either in Life or in my personal
skill sets awesome and what is more
important than leveling up your
financial ability guys all it takes to
pay someone is their phone number email
or cash tag you can even scan the QR
code straight from the app and you'll
see your balance updated immediately so
you always know when a payment went
through also Securities top-notch over a
cash app from security locks that
encryption cash app uses Advanced
features to keep you and your money safe
you can also browse topics find
resources or chat with a human cash app
support has answers to all of your
questions and don't forget that you can
save on everyday spending Gamers get
exclusive discounts with cash app pay
and cash app card damn so you can Bank
the way you want a faster simpler way to
bank without so many fees so if you want
to level up your life you've got to
level up your money you can download a
cash app in the link in the description
it's available on Google Play Store and
the App Store with no hidden fees and a
free to order debit card it feels like a
cheat code for your finances back to the
video or I guess we're on the topic of
memes uh people need to stop [__]
memeing films with cameras I I don't
know like they're like the recently I've
seen this where what do you mean so I I
because I'm really really excited for to
watch uh is it enter the spider verse or
into the spot no the second spider-verse
the second spider-verse film and I feel
like a lot of plot points of that have
already been ruined for me because
people have posted like cam rip memes
and for some reason YouTube has decided
it's a really nice uh it's you know I've
obviously put interest in it YouTubers
just recommended me a bunch of [__] and
I'm like okay I understand like memeing
stuff but like cameras really why
watching cameras come on come on Mac
come on guys come on you know no that's
not cool yeah I don't know why a single
person would ever watch a camera it's
actually unbearable yeah I think I would
rather you're just ruining any film that
you would want to watch yeah come on man
yeah but I don't know yeah but back in
the day I remember I used to when I was
a kid oh yeah because you didn't know
any better so I was like man I can watch
the Miley Cyrus movie let's go [__]
one okay Miley Cyrus
that was back when I think you know
streaming even like 720p was like kind
of crazy yeah everything was normally
480. the 4x3 aspect yeah yeah yeah it
was like you know you'd get normally all
the films would be ripped in 480p and it
was like well a camera
you may as well just throw another wood
in the fire I don't know it's already
[__] yeah and now we're like yeah now
Apple has just announced uh Apple Vision
or whatever right yeah quite a while ago
but I mean yeah it looked [__] weird
I just saw the Marcus Brownlee video on
that uh yesterday yeah
um of him like reviewing it and uh I
don't know what do you boys think about
it are we okay first are we sold on VR
or ar yet I don't know if I'm sold on it
yet you know what do you mean I don't
know because uh
uh so I've been trying out like some VR
like a little bit more recently not too
much just like surface level stuff you
know like stuff like VR chat and played
around with that a bit and I'm like
I don't know I get it but I cannot ever
see myself committing to it you know uh
it's just uncomfortable end of the day
it's just uncomfortable right I think um
it's hard to say because we don't know
where it's going to be in 10 years or 20
years I mean it looks promising uh but
it also looks dystopian as [__] yeah so
it's kind of like a it reminds me of
when like Google Glass first came out
yeah I mean it makes you realize how far
ahead of the the curve Google Glass was
so far ahead of
what anything that it should have been
yeah um and it looked good and you know
Apple are generally I I don't buy Apple
products yeah but you know they're
pretty reliable with making pretty
Innovative stuff or it might be an
expensive piece of tech that you're like
cool this was fun never gonna use this I
mean it's three and a half Grand like
yeah yeah no the average person is not
going to be buying this okay but here's
here's the thing right here's the thing
because there's been like a lot of horn
game that's for sure I mean I mean that
I mean that already exists you know we
are better
in 4k there is one use for the new
athlete you can spend three thousand
five hundred dollars to watch porn in
four like 8K important people are great
at adopting new technology funny enough
they're the biggest innovators uh when
it comes to like digital media I feel
like if you want to see what updates
YouTube is gonna Implement in like two
years just go into PornHub and you're
like ah PornHub did this like two years
ago yeah right
they're on that VR game before YouTube
was yeah I don't know I feel like there
has or like there's they've been like
Tech in the past that has gotten a lot
of hype that has just like for one
reason or another like never caught on
right uh I think like the one uh one
that comes off of the top of my head uh
it's like Segways you know way way way
okay okay I was not expecting that yeah
that was but I was attracting 500
explain your thought process explain my
thought process yeah uh you know when
when the Segway got announced there was
a lot of hype that it was going to
revolutionize Street travel you know
it's what yeah Americans will literally
do anything
and then you know look look uh look
where the Segway got now you know it
just turned up to be turned out to be a
a failure of Epic I mean it killed its
creators yeah yeah yeah I mean it killed
his creator died from us and you know
there was there's a there was a lot of
hype around let's say e-scooters and you
know it's
arguable whether they've taken on or you
know whether I mean it's taken on more
than the Segway that's for sure it does
take a normal you know I think the form
factor of the scooter helps a lot though
I mean Segway isn't huge but when you
think about storing yeah it's way more
manageable yeah also there's just
something about a Segway for the longest
time I looked at it and I'm just like
you just kind of look like a tool yeah
riding one and I can't explain why and
it always comes back to everyone okay
it's interesting though why do you think
that do you think it's just that you're
like t-posing basically
it's like no I must go to work goodbye
you look ridiculous yeah when you write
a sequel you look down yeah I mean I
look cool writing I I totally agree with
you
um because I do think you look dumb
riding a Segway
um but you know we've all written
Segways actually pretty fun uh
surprisingly actually super fun uh but
I'm wondering because my first
experiences with something like a Segway
was just seeing uh seeing it in like
dumb pieces of media like seeing it in
in a random YouTube video as like a you
know to
um to parody like the nerd or something
like that or in like [__] Pool Mart
or Paul like the mall cop [__] movie
that I can't remember
or something like that and I'm like okay
Segway that's dumb that's dumb and
stupid you know
um I think what was more dumb though was
like not even like those kinds of
Segways with the handles but the ones
that is just the feet yeah oh you know
you know those ones where you just like
step on it the hoverboards things like I
don't know what a [__] name yeah that's
another one where I'm just like you
could be the the badass [__]
with like infinite res once you're on a
hoverboard you have lost all the risk
you just look like a tool riding yeah so
so the reason I bring these up like like
the hoverboard as well which is just
like you know I feel like went and you
know came and went through it was kind
of like a fad a trend you know and I'm
like both of these to me tried to solve
a problem that didn't really exist you
know it's it like Segway solved the
problem of Transport for for whoms you
know well you know for more cops yeah
yeah more cops
I realize after you you know you you use
a Segway and I actually the inherent
abilities I guess Segway has above other
I guess transport methods yeah indoors
it's pretty good in like spaces like
malls yeah yeah yeah yeah but outside of
that it's a bite of courses you know
that would be real be really good for
golfers golf carts golf carts
that's true that's true and then you
kind of realize oh wait e-bikes are just
better than Segways because it's more
stable you can have a basket yeah you
know it's more natural as well yeah
you're sitting down it's a lot more
comfortable yeah you kind of realize and
and there's a lot of infrastructure
already for bike parking yeah so you're
kind of like oh e-bikes are just a
better version a better version of uh
what Segways tried to be I guess it
makes it good I mean yeah you've ridden
e-bikes
um you know whenever I've I've driven on
my friends e-bikes as well they're very
very good yeah
um and uh you know okay so I guess going
back to like apple Vision okay looks
wise looks ridiculous all right you uh
the [__] the fact that you can see
the eyes on the other side just makes
you look like a [__] cyborg I'm like
if Apple can't make it look cool ain't
no one there ain't no way anyone's gonna
look cool
yeah yeah
but it's like because the way that they
do it is that like it's not actually the
eyes it's not like a transparent screen
where like you can just see the person's
eyes it's a reflection or I guess a an
image of what the inside camera views
your eyes at yeah it's been projected
onto it yeah so it just enlarges your
eyes
so you just look like an insect yeah
yeah sounds fun and uh you know I you
know the the biggest thing I thought and
uh because I haven't tried out the Apple
Vision yet none of us have obviously the
only only Marcus hasn't yeah we are not
um
yeah but like what's uh is like with ar
and like VR Tech in general like what uh
what problem are we trying to solve here
what are we I think it's like trying to
offer especially with ar it's like
trying to offer more ways to interact
with an environment or like let's say
you had like I don't know you could if
you were like a 3D modeler or an
architect right like it's like oh come
come to the architect office put on
these goggles look right there we've got
this 3D design of this building you can
kind of interact with it it gives you
another layer of like kind of presenting
I'm sure that's what people said about
it but that's like okay what you
describe is such a specific situation I
mean think about it with like a computer
back in the day they probably had the
same argument
adding up numbers that's so specific I'm
not I can add it just fine with the with
the [__] bead thing what are they
called the the what the Abacus yeah the
Abacus right here bro we don't need that
like I I think it's again with
technology like this I think it's more
about like
trying to find a u-ship right away is
not the correct way of looking at
technology it's like let's make it let's
make the tool people will figure out how
to I guarantee like when it comes to the
Apple Vision it was probably just a
bunch of like Tech heads who like
watched Iron Man and saw Jarvis and was
just like that looks cool I wanna I
wanna do this yeah you know but I think
there is this like it's you know it's
also presumably if if this does work
because apparently it's just you clicks
like this right yeah that's way more
accessible in terms of
um technology than if you know what if
you're a person who has very limited
movement in your hands for some reason
yeah you know using a smartphone could
be difficult you know people use you
know some people who are quite disabled
have pens in their mouth or they have
some other solution or text-to-speech
whatever yeah there's always more ways
of of using technology acting with it
also uh I guess I mean the fact that you
could just have a display that is like
your entire Vision like if you could
watch a movie in 4k that sounds kind of
it's literally a HUD yeah
you just have your entire Vision taken
out for it but again it's like how will
it actually work and I mean for me it's
like the comfort thing would I ever
choose to watch a movie in like with a
big [__] absolutely
I think it's like the death of Cinema
yeah yeah would I ever choose to watch
it probably not because even just
playing around in VR for like a few
hours I'm like I need to take this off
I'm like yeah I've tried watching a
movie on my VR headset because I was
like I was just curious I was just
curious I was like okay like they
[__] advertise that like you can
watch movies in VR and it's like you're
actually in the cinema I'm like all
right let me try this so I tried with my
VR headset the I have an Oculus too so I
traded with the Oculus too 30 minutes in
I'm just like I can't see anything
because the sweat is just like coming
over my eyes
is just burning from like staring at the
screen that's right here and I'm like I
don't think I'm going to be doing that I
think also as well there's could be a
benefit in you know obviously right now
that price point is ridiculous yeah but
down the line it'll probably get cheaper
as as uh new technology comes out yes
yeah if this could be like a all-in-one
replacement for a PC TV phone even that
could be quite promising and it could
give you know that technology could be
more accessible to people in a lot of
people I mean it's first generation Tech
right now it's more you have to kind of
figure it out from that I personally it
freaks me out and I'm not a big fan of
it but I think not on kind of being
against the idea of progressing it is
kind of
um I understood not helpful right and
they'll say yeah it's not helpful but I
guess I guess to play Devil's advocacy
as well to play Devil's Advocate uh like
one thing that I've learned I've come to
despise within the past five years is
the whole Tech bro culture you know like
bro like adopting Tech yo nfts crypto
this is new technology it's not about
the tools man it's not a fad mom I swear
yeah yeah so it's like because because
of this it's kind of like giving me a
more critical eye whenever a new piece
of tech gets announced to be like do we
actually need this well yeah because
it's like you know I is this gonna be a
fat like like kind of a Viking Tech in
like 2018 2019 was kind of like becoming
kind of trendy yeah you know being up up
to date yeah you know and then nfts came
out and Bitcoin blew up and all that
stuff and I was like oh man
you go back to bullying
nfts made me actually think like there
are benefits to being yeah which is not
to say that Apple vision is on the same
level as nfts or like [__] crypto
whatever
um but you know it does make me think
could I ever see this you know I mean
Google Glasses like you said was way
ahead of its time but it still did not
take off right well no because it was it
was [__] it was too ahead of us
I I think people just don't want people
walking around with cameras on their
face the entire time yeah I think it
freaks people out like it looks like
you're a spy yeah yeah I mean you know I
know I do there's IRL stream so people
just look yeah I mean I'm I'm definitely
not going to be buying buying the Vision
Pro thing but like I am curious to see
where this Tech is going to go and again
with with tech more often than not the
first one is always by far [__] yeah
yeah just just wait for it yeah it'd be
fascinating to see like how it's gonna
evolve in like the next five ten years
right it's like foldable phones right
yeah no one [__] knew the foldable
phone but they're like it sounds kind of
cool that's an option and like right
like the first two generations I think
were kind of yeah and then I'm hoping
third fourth generation foldable phones
will actually be really affordable
smartphones yeah yeah okay what do you
think I meant um
that's the Boomer in me that's [__]
right there that's flip he's a foldable
phone it's different okay
I don't understand foldable phones
though I love the idea of having a phone
and then being able to turn it into like
a pseudo kind of tablet on the go
because I I have an iPad I don't use it
um I have not used it at once right
because I'm too lazy to carry it because
I'm sorry I'm like I just won't shut my
phone but I would love the idea of like
I'm watching and I'm like I'm like two
of these
that'd be nice well I can't get over
because I've seen people who are I've
seen uh dinosaurs and I'm like I can't
get over the crease well that's that's
the idea right is that hopefully in a
generation or two the crease will get
better yeah yeah yeah but apparently you
just live with it yeah yeah you just
live with it I guess like mesothelium or
whatever that is in America that every
ad tells you about on TV the what what
you know what you know in America would
you put the TV on it's like have you or
a loved one suffer from mesothelioma
call call the lawyer have you ever seen
these ads
all right and well there's that too but
every goddamn thing is like a lawyer ad
and it's like yeah it's like have you or
a loved one been affected by
mesothelioma let me see what the actual
word is I've never heard of that yes you
have before yes you have yes that
doesn't even sound like that sounds like
a mythical creature
mesothelioma a type of cancer that
develops in the lining that covers the
outer serves uh uh what trigger is it
yeah
yeah I mean uh oh no because apparently
you just live with it I guess if I have
something in my teeth drive me crazy no
no okay Carry On when was the last time
you flossed I don't floss
you don't floss I don't know I don't
floss okay okay flossing is a is a
conspiracy by big American Dental
Associates
I I am just I know that you should floss
yeah I know that it's beneficial I just
I can't be [__] I just don't care yeah
and I feel like brushing my teeth and
mouthwash is enough
mentally
do you floss every day I don't know I
hate the I hate the feeling of flossing
yeah it's horrible yeah it feels like a
torture man it feels like I'm cutting
into my teeth and gums yeah I've lost
every now and again I actually like the
feeling I don't know I don't know why I
you know because apparently you know
when it starts bleeding and everything
that's like a good thing right
oh well yeah because you're getting all
the gunk out right yeah getting with the
gun cow I don't know it's just something
I just leave the gunk there that that's
on you bro
you should call up a lawyer yeah there
is some there is
there is something satisfying about
leaving you know you're supposed to go
to the dentist like what once every six
months or something like that yeah
something like that yeah they've been
emailing I don't know Brit who goes to
the dentist once every six months that's
where the meme starts yeah this is where
the meme started right but there is
something satisfying about the feeling
of like you're you know getting your
teeth cleaned and you know getting all
the gunk out between uh between your
teeth it's just satisfying it is a
[__] not the it's not a drill or
whatever it is I don't know what it is
super high pressure water dude I hate it
it hurts my ears so much
um I think the dentist is I I the older
I've gotten The more I've appreciated
people who are afraid of the dentist I
I've become I've begun to read spies
going yes there's anything wrong with my
teeth but just because I hate the whole
process yeah and I hate hospitals and
dentists
both of them I really despise yeah I
mean it sounds like you have like some
buried trauma in there somewhere which
we're gonna uncover one day on trash
Chase if we talk about this enough [__]
I don't know it's the thought of someone
operating on me is terrifying do you
ever have like a cavity growing up uh
yeah one cavity I had a Mercury one oh
yeah that's right and then yeah in Japan
they fixed it they were like let's get
rid of that that's gonna give you
misthenia
I know many yeah I mean those those
aren't even the American ads that like
I've like confused me the most do you
know what the American ads like I find
like wild some of that like like I find
the wildest the medicine not the
medicine ones the political ones oh I I
just I can't I do not understand John
Johnson wants to keep rapists out of
prison in your home
yeah if they sign up for that and also
he wants to raise the taxes
they always they always start with that
and then they end off with the taxes
afterwards yeah Annie wants to raise
taxes as well but also rapists out of
Prisons what can I say
Deborah Jones wants to teach your kids
to be gay don't vote for Deborah Jones
vote for John Johnson he's like what the
[__]
hinge
oh my god oh those oh my God I I
remember on tour when we had that like
TV going on in the bus the entire time
just like 24 7 just some random fun yeah
sure so cool having a TV on a bus yeah I
would say epic but like I remember every
like third or fourth ad was just this
like you know like are you suffering
from depression oh yeah I'll try out
glimaclobia yeah and then it's like side
effects side effects
side effects may include diarrhea
bleeding anus pregnancy it's like okay
yeah I always because my only exposure
to Those ads growing up was like through
I guess like YouTube parodies and [__]
like that I always thought they weren't
real yeah and then the first time I was
in America and I saw that ad I remember
I looked at arcade I'm like these are
real I thought those are parodies I
literally thought they were just
parodies you'd see every now and again
you know this thing will uh give me
diarrhea and uh six types of cancer but
hey at least it whitens my teeth like
okay sure it's very weird and then I
guess there's so many stuff you can get
over the counter which in most of the
countries in the world you just can't
yeah crazy you're like I can just take
melatonin every night and no one's gonna
tell me maybe I shouldn't yeah that's on
the label and it's like yeah yeah I mean
there are a lot of drugs that you can't
like fly with even if you're prescribed
with them in America I mean if you come
to Japan don't bring your Adderall
prescription because your Adderall is uh
running as well yeah oh dude that
reminds me I've been uh speaking about
Japan because that's the place we live
in yeah I've been following a lot of the
Japan reddits thing just reading up
what's happening yeah and uh Japan read
it yeah there's loads of Japan Reddit
focused ones oh okay live in Japan
people who visiting Japan yeah Japan and
uh uh obviously there's been a lot of
weird [__] happening but um there was
like uh obviously there was that video
of that guy that you covered
um when everyone was trying to like
[__] harass him but all the IRL
streamers yeah yeah and luckily he's
laughed now oh he has yeah finally uh
and uh there was a like I think I found
bizarre is that there was like all these
American news stations and people online
posting me like oh there's an American
missing in in Japan and no one heard
anything yeah and then I think the
police just again at the time of
recording it was like the police just
detained I think them and you didn't
tell the government and when the
government asked they were like we're
not we're not going to tell you yes why
what yeah they just wouldn't they that's
what they assume because the police
won't look for them yeah but they won't
tell them where they are so everyone's
assuming that they're detained okay it's
so bizarre
um yeah that you could get detained and
then that even legal I I think yeah I
think it is in Japan I mean you follow
the country's laws and it's
um so many other stuff there's so many
interesting things like there was this
thing where
this dude on one of the reddits uh
he was he was walking at home on one day
and this dude was cycling and he I guess
he nearly bumped into the guy and then
swerved off hit a pole and then died
when he hit the pole Jesus and then this
whole subreddit was accounting about how
the wife of the dead husband was like
harassing the dude's house uh asking for
like money yeah being like what you what
the [__] you killed my husband and stuff
and the police weren't doing anything
and then eventually the police did
something how hard did he hit that
[__] pole that's what I was wondering
you're just chilling and a dude dies
right next to you you're like what the
[__]
as well there's so many strange things
people people are encountering yeah
because I I do a lot of like that kind
of like weird Japan music yeah I have a
lot of those um one that hasn't been
released yet as of this video that I
thought was funny was um I know hideaki
you know the creator of Evangelical he
got dogs the other day are you serious
some random fan at a gas station what so
so the story goes is that hopefully that
video will be up by the time this
episode's up but like yeah basically
it's Anna was just like I'm just gonna
go for a drive oh I gotta go fill up
some gas so he just goes to his local
gas station fills it up the guy who was
at the cash register was like oh my God
you're [__] under hirayaki I love
everything you do and he wanted to brag
about it on Twitter that he met Arno
hideaki so what he does is instead of
just doing a standard tweet of just
saying like I met I know he was at my
gas station it was awesome he took a
picture of his receipt no no and put it
up being like see even his signature is
right there but the problem was was that
all of his credit card information oh my
God his car registration even where the
gas station was was just all there and
people are like uh you should probably
delete that
Rose losing his job and more oh he lost
his job yeah yeah yeah that's that's a
minimum of what actually the gas the the
gas station company I think it's
anything else had to make a public
apology
being like uh we're sorry that our
employee uh had a massive [__] up
someone that is someone getting sued and
yeah rightly so yeah right that is all
of your private information that you
know and amidst all the backlash you got
right of people being like what the [__]
right he was just like the only defense
he made was like no I swear it was the
real honor and people were like that's
not what we're on
oh we see
his full of his private information
whether it was really on though like we
know we know the last four digits of his
credit card because you [__] posted
it yeah I guess he's just out there then
he's just out there yeah now people have
like starting to figure out like
whereabouts he lives and [__] and it's
just like all because of this dumbass
just dumb [__] like that and yeah police
probably not doing anything about it
I mean unless something horrible happens
when TSA when they when they recognize
us and I just handed them my passport
I'm like bruh
I'm like [__] you could just
memorize this on YouTube post about it
or something I know that they would yeah
yeah
oh my god oh I had that the other day
actually at like my local uh corn bini
yeah oh yeah um like I have a company
really close to my house I'm not gonna
say which one obviously but like I went
there it was like at 11 p.m family mom
yeah one of the three
um I went there like 11 p.m I was just
like you know I was in my pajamas
because I was getting ready for bed I
just wanted to go get something and I
went give the guy you know all my stuff
and I'm just looking down on my phone
you know waiting for them to finish and
I just hear oh my God and I look up and
the dude behind the counter is like
you're the anime man oh God and in my
head I'm like rip I have to move now
because he spoke English I think he was
uh like Indian or Saudi or something
yeah so and you know he seemed like a
really nice guy more Saudi how did you
know he was a brown boy
he was a brown boy uh but uh you know he
was chill about it thankfully but in my
head I'm just like don't you dare follow
me out afterwards after this purchase
because I'm literally right there oh no
have you ever had that like yeah someone
recognizing you really close to your
house yes yes it's terrifying everything
actually there there's this one time
where it happened literally on my street
your street is not near March the
tourist stuff that's that's that's the
thing right so I was walking with mine
yeah so so I was walking to my apartment
uh and uh I was on my street and um uh I
got recognized and my house is really
close and just to make sure I walked
like three blocks extra down and then
turned around and walked back
I was like I ain't take ing this risk
right now man this is something new I'm
experiencing now I feel very vulnerable
yeah uh but yeah it is it is weird yeah
but have you has that ever happened to
you as well oh yeah yeah fair amount
yeah but but you know I'm just paranoid
whenever I see another white person in
my house I'm like
there's a chance I like try to make eye
contact with them so I'm like come on
like if you're SAS prove it
give me the look give me the look yeah
give me the look I'm like let's just run
outside my house because I'm like I just
don't want to risk it yeah
um yeah luckily there's a few entrances
so I can just walk around and then it's
definitely gone scarier now that you
know uh all the tourists are coming back
just I feel like every time I go out now
I'm more aware yeah of just every single
like non-japanese person who walks past
me I'm just like
yeah but I mean like if it seems like
every month now there's like a new video
popping up of someone doing something
stupid in a live stream or a YouTuber
doing something stupid yeah I'm like
come on man we're working so hard to try
to give like keep the peace here I mean
more content for me so yeah Joey's likes
my bills here yeah yeah it's just like
my must be a good boy yeah and I'm like
oh this is this is what this is why like
[__] Charlie has so many things to
talk about like everything he wakes up
right I can see now yeah has it gotten
more difficult for you since like all
that news and stuff has broken out no I
mean again the the way I've always
approached it is that most places we're
like oh so you eat this guy you know you
just ask them is it okay if I have the
camera you know and sometimes they'll
just flat out say no and it's like you
know if there's a bar that says no it's
not like you'll have difficulty finding
another bar yeah yeah and also you know
a lot of the streamers who uh Do It full
time like Rob uh Rob CD who streams
full-time you know he he goes to the
same places and interacts with them and
they're very understanding and they're
like yeah you're cool I know it's fine I
know yeah yeah customers and there is
there's some bars where they love it so
it's kind of just about finding those
spots and not shoving in a camera and
someone's face she doesn't want it yeah
um be not being a dick IRL is is super
easy uh yeah no tell that to these other
diggers but a lot of people make it look
[__] difficult yeah like you just you
just think you're going to become like
some kind of monster when you're
streaming outside yeah like it's very
easy to not be a dick I will admit that
every time I have seen like news of just
like some dumbass IRL streamer in Japan
you know making it's always somebody
who's turning up like it's never someone
who lives here but I always but I always
but I always worry for people like you
and Rob that you know yeah yeah this
[__] keeps persisting then it's just
gonna put a bad name on ireling for sure
yeah yeah it's definitely a worry
because it's like I think it's such a
good content uh it's great content type
if the person doing it right it's done
right exactly exactly and it's so much
interesting stuff you can do in Japan
that's so cool you can do it and luckily
you know I I think he was doing some
kind of there was a guy visiting he was
doing he was blaring like music in
Disneyland and saying racist things oh
yeah yeah yeah the kickstreamer right
yeah
and stuff like that's bad because like I
mean you can't stream in Disneyland
anyway yeah you you know you shouldn't
be able to do that but
um you worry that other businesses will
be like flat out like no yeah yeah but
luckily in Japan a lot of the cool stuff
anyway are not giant conglomerates it's
like it's just local stores that you can
just be like hey is it cool if I I won't
film any customers I'm just gonna do my
own thing and that's that's where a lot
of the best stuff is anyway yeah so I'm
not too worried about it but it's more
so the perception like people are kind
of I feel Japan especially and Japanese
people are very easily uh convinced and
I guess like indoctrinated by looking at
negative media surrounding you know
things like streaming and youtubing and
stuff like that and think like oh well
if this one [__] did it then they
all must be like this right and you know
that's the problem with them just being
educated on the medium but it's like you
know you can't really blame them either
because only the bad [__] gets you know
gets published and then that just
reflects on all the other people like us
who are just trying to you know make
videos and stream and you know make it
an honest living yeah yeah and I'm just
worried that like it's people like that
that are gonna ruin it for the rest of
us well yeah it sucks that one guy going
around Disneyland chatting racist things
would get 10 times more media attention
than you know if I did like a cyclathon
race like yeah
exactly in the Japanese lens of things I
mean that's just true I think that's
just I think that's just in general you
know I know I know well I think a little
bit online at least not not not so much
on traditional media but at least online
people are pretty good at hyping up good
events and and oh for sure talking about
them uh I mean they very much love
negative stuff too
um but you know you just gotta hope that
for every every one one brick you can
add someone doesn't tear down a hundred
uh I mean I mean it's difficult because
I think uh it's difficult to
promote something positive in the sea or
of negativity because I'm surprised you
said the online space because I think
the online space is the biggest space
that's kind of like accentuates negative
drives yeah negative like negativity uh
and I think that's just human nature I
think it's just human nature in general
you know we love spilling the team yeah
yeah I think I think it feels like
negativity is weighed a lot more and it
most certainly is but I find that like
the longevity of kind of positive uh
things you've done will maybe in the
moment not be as as big news as
something negative yeah I find that over
time people do remember us oh they they
do remember and also like I also think
that like
in terms of
um for streaming it kind of needs to to
have what YouTube has had where you know
in like Japan
um they have like hika kin right who's
like this they're like they're PewDiePie
Mysteries whatever you want to compare
like their biggest YouTuber having
someone like that be the face and who is
great for Brands and and people know is
a name brand you want to work with it
really helps kind of uh establish
creators and I think that streaming just
needs more of that yeah it just needs
more established creators who work with
these Brands work within the rules do
what they say like legitimizes the
medium yeah yeah you know create great
content while not compromising but but
also keeping the people that are working
with
um happy and and making sure that
everyone's kind of benefiting for sure
yeah um and I think streaming just needs
more of that um
just in general yeah I think right now
we're just streaming just just does a
lot of the big streamers I just I I
whether they realize it or not I think
they're just hurting the medium uh even
though maybe that profiting and doing
well themselves I think the the overall
landscape of it is is like not great
yeah I mean I would argue that that's
just not in Japan that's just in general
in general too too but Japan needs it as
well because the thing the thing about
the thing I've noticed about streamer
culture
um in general uh you know even if there
are people making exciting content it's
just just because of this the way the
medium works the pure amounts of hours
that's you know around content that
people produce uh a lot of that content
revolves around tea and opinions and
reactions you know and it's you know
we've you know with something like
YouTube it's much more controllable you
can make a certain video you have
someone like Mr Beast doing all these
amazing stuff and you know for every you
know [__] cyclathon chess boxing
event there is 10 million hours of
reacting to stupid tick tockers and uh
and drama you know and and that's just
that that's just the truth of the matter
you know yeah yeah uh and you just have
to hope that the platform will kind of
grow up
I don't think that's gonna happen
I feel like YouTube to its credit like
has matured a lot like oh 100 the the
the scene of YouTubers like think about
like genuinely like think about YouTube
drama it is so different yeah now from
what it once was yeah yeah four years
ago three years ago like it's completely
changed and I think streaming will get
that over time
um obviously I think it's a little
tougher because it's live people are
more emotional no editing yeah
um but but I think it will mature I
think I think it's it's like YouTube it
hit that mainstream drama was huge yeah
and then people realized hey maybe this
is not so good for business okay I mean
I mean just look at how often scarce up
was now yeah he barely uploads because
there's nothing to talk about whereas
full four or five years ago as you said
it was like every day there was
something happening on the YouTube scene
yeah and then a lot of the drama covered
by YouTube is often as streaming drama
yeah yeah exactly and I think I think
that maybe there'll always be a space
for that in streaming because it's more
like big brother yeah that's more Truman
Show yeah yeah he's gonna have that but
I think I think it will mature again she
needs more time I mean I think one of
the big things actually uh interestingly
enough is that I think creators
themselves we just grew up yeah
officially like physically grew up you
know and we we are the audience that is
going to be the next generation of
YouTubers will will you know they'll
learn from us yeah they'll learn like
the way that we do things and and
hopefully they'll they'll they'll take
their behavior because because there are
genuine like YouTubers now who are let's
say Role Models you know who have been
on this platform for like a long time
and have like physically grown up and of
course there's gonna always gonna be
younger creators but unlike a platform
like Tick Tock which is like very very
young right now there's a lot of people
doing like a lot of stupid [__] on Tick
Tock
um that's just because it's it's a very
young platform and people have not grown
up with that platform so much as people
have grown up with YouTube also you know
a lot of streamers the woman armies
maybe they have an editor or something
or maybe an assistant but you know
YouTube we're at the scale now where I
know I can count at least 10 plus
YouTubers I know with uh teams of 10 or
more yeah there are a lot of like these
are these are these are companies these
are all like businesses and you can't
you you don't want to be [__] around
with your livelihood of people who work
below you right yeah it's more about you
know I think again it's just a maturity
thing I think it's not not so much the
creators but it's it's the platform and
I think streaming will become more
mature over time which will help it I
think I think we'll you know now there's
uh you know you can go to certain places
and they have guidelines clearly laid
out for YouTubers or whatever to how to
film something you know and I think
it'll get there too yeah um and I think
that's a spider kid around it yeah I can
only hope I mean maybe it won't be in
people can play Devil's Advocate until
I'm wrong I'm stupid but I'd like to
think it'll mature yeah and I guess I
guess I guess we've unlike I I'm sensing
like an unintentional theme of this
podcast so far we're talking about the
future a lot so I want to I want to
bring up gaming right let's talk about
tech we've talked about YouTube all
right I saw this I saw this video
recently that's the title yeah I I was
like I had the light bulb moment what do
we think the future's gonna be okay so I
saw this video of this I think game in
development right now which is like on
like unreal five or something and it's
so photorealistic I it literally oh oh
is it the the one with the the first
person shooter one yeah yeah yeah the
one uh [__] what's it called were you
like killing uh people in like an
abandoned building yeah yeah yeah yeah
that one have you have you seen that one
oh this episode is brought to you by
ship station I am trying to automize
everything in my life I don't want to
have to do anything unless I have to do
it that's where ship station comes in
today well Connor what is there left to
min max in your life what can ship
station do for all of us well God as you
know I am constantly trying to get rid
of the stuff that I win in my crane game
videos and I'm shipping them off to all
my viewers which you can get yourself
but thank God a shipstation it becomes
easy shipstation makes it easy to
automate shipping tasks for orders from
every Marketplace in One dashboard
there's effortless integration
everywhere you sell online including
Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify and a whole lot
more plus you can manage every order
from one simple dashboard print shipping
labels easily compare rates and delivery
times to optimize every shipment and
automate delivery notifications you know
what I don't have a dripped company like
Joey that sounds like a headache to set
up but you know what with ship station
it's so easy and there's a free trial as
well in case you don't know if you want
to use the service long term with
industry leading discounts you'll never
worry about overpaying for shipment get
up to 84 off USPS and UPS ratings and if
that's not enough you can use our promo
code to try shipstation free for two
months so what are you waiting for spend
more time growing your business when you
automate shipping tasks with shipstation
go to shipstation.com and use coupon
code trash today and sign up for your
free 60-day trial 60 days that's
shipstation.com code trash thank you
very much the shipstation for sponsoring
this episode back to the video so I just
showed Joey the trailer of unrecord
which is the name of the game in uh
early gameplay this is official early
Gameplay trailer
um and to me that base that that does
look undistinguishable from real life
yeah uh from the trader alone at least
and I'm like do I want this I don't
think I do want this you know do I want
actual one photo realism in my [__]
VR sets in my you know Apple Vision
[__] 20 you know it's bro like serial
experiments Lane was right like real the
and the digital is like slowly starting
to become one yeah yeah I think for
I I think one thing that it could help
with is Maybe
training and I know that some Industries
do actually use this already yeah but
like training for like very uh dangerous
kind of jobs and like experience like if
you're a firefighter yeah you can do an
accurate simulation of what it would
look like yeah to be in a house on fire
oh that would be very useful I don't
know they essentially just set buildings
on fire anyway yeah the training but
yeah
um you know I think there's there's a
lot of places where it could help I
don't know if shooting someone that
would help they'll ever train people
with the military they'll be like I I I
think if we're going into okay you know
we we talk about the dystopian Black
Mirror Future parody a lot but the Apple
Vision generally does remind me of Black
Mirror oh yeah generally unironically
looking at the trailer looking at what
Apple yeah you've seen it reminded me of
the most in Black Mirror again I think
it's in season one where he's having sex
with his wife and he's playing oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah that one he's playing
back the good sex he had with his wife
because the current sex isn't good yeah
imagine two couples wearing like uh they
like filmed each other having the best
sex ever and they're just reliving that
yeah oh
God honey what's wrong you uh you
haven't put on your Apple Vision today
I mean it's like I can't get hard
wait hold on honey I need my Apple
Vision to get in the mood
can you imagine it's like hold it they
you know she uh your wife's lying on bed
and she's like hold on honey I gotta get
ready and he comes out with the Apple
Vision on his head and he's like honey
I'm ready she's like I'm not in the mood
my one's still charging me I can't I
can't do it tonight sorry babe I don't I
don't need glasses at all so the thought
of even putting anything on my eyes for
more than like two hours yeah not even
like glasses I'm like this sounds
uncomfortable yeah all right yeah I like
the freedom of my face yeah yeah exactly
and why are you laughing I love that
freedom the freedom of the freedom
I want a giant screen in front of me I
don't want a giant screen here yeah yeah
and I mean like with like let's say
photo realistic games it's it's
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't scare me
as much as the idea just makes me
uncomfortable right because I always
like the feeling of let's say any piece
of media gaming movies uh anime whatever
there is like there's the fourth War
there there is there is that distinction
like there's that distinction between
this is the real world and I get to
enjoy whatever the game is allow me to
enjoy in the comfort of the safe space
knowing that it's it's a virtual world
once when I see when I see a Gameplay
trailer trailer like this I'm like this
this is too real now I'm like this is
there this is getting to the point where
mentally I don't know if my brain can
distinguish this from just you know
doing something I feel especially if you
like ended up playing a game like that
on the Apple Vision yeah that would be
like that would actually be like a real
like simulation like a metal gear [__]
like yeah that would be that would
actually be like you know like oh
violence in video games bad and uh you
know all like the mom's complaining
about it that'll be the time where I
would be like and you know what actually
maybe I kind of you know what Mom you're
right yeah you know what maybe you have
a point I wonder if there's ever be a
point where like a kid would have to be
aware of like two worlds almost like the
real world and the virtual world because
it's so indistinguishable if you get so
good where he's like okay this is that
must be so weird to grow up and having
two things that look and feel exactly
the same but one of them is totally
different and uh how do you even process
you literally just described the plot of
serials that is exactly what that talks
about I haven't seen it and they talked
about that [__] in 1998 like they they
saw it and it's scary to think that it's
become either like you said it's it's
getting to that point where I would look
at that and if you had never told me
that was Unreal Engine yeah I would have
thought that was like some [__] body
a kid would have no way of understanding
what what that is yeah if it was you
know if it was let's say it's perfect
which obviously isn't yeah you know you
know kind of a cool problem that we're
gonna have to deal with
yeah I mean it's it's kind of like the
more the more that you know exciting new
tech comes out the population is going
to decline so no one is going to [__] is
what I'm learning Japan Japanese
I think the highest birth rate in Asia
right now yeah yeah it does it does
career is like negative 500 that is
because they have League yeah yeah it is
that was like the one thing that she had
was holding back they were like I want
my league it won't get popular we all
have babies there are more internet
cafes than children
Japan's like there is nothing worse than
gacha games in careers like that League
of Legends
Legends really is the the population
control
[Laughter]
dystopian population control [__]
League of Legends gacha games and
YouTubers that's it China was like one
child policy Korea was like League of
Legends
I think Korea's birth rate was like 0.0
uh 0.5 or something holy [__] that's
really bad Jesus Korea's really really
bad right now Asia
Asians maybe it's the Asians yeah
no y'all need to go outside and [__]
yeah
no because like yeah I personally for me
with video games the more that you know
the more that I've grown up the more
I've just appreciated stylized like the
whole like stylized graphics and style
shaded stuff I [__] loves and I don't
know if this is a this is definitely a
me preference thing right uh because
I've always like I was fine with like
the Call of Duty phase like the real
kind of like the real more more
realistic looking shooters or everything
but I always loved the more let's say
car not cartoonish but the more yeah
like stylized expressive I feel like
that's more expressive you know like
Wind Waker Jet Set Radio type of games
right yeah I mean it's one of my
favorite games of all time and I've
already upset this but like I think
metal slog is just one of those games
that is aged so well yeah and it looks
it is a work of art today they went the
the work they put into making those
Sprites I mean oh my God everything
about that game is so good it is it is
one it is some of the most beautiful
explosion Sprites I've ever seen the age
so well it's so nice so well they went
above and beyond but I feel that's why
especially in like the Indie like game
scene right like those kinds of like 16
by 32-bit games are still so popular
yeah a lot of people still look at them
being like you know what I love how
realistic games are becoming and you
know to the point where it's almost
indistinguishable but there's something
charming and special about this like
retro look you know whatever whatever it
might be I saw a meme it was like indie
game devs trying to decide what they
wanted their game to be and it was that
you know that guy about to press the
button yeah and it was like uh roguelike
uh metroidvania
platformer
I guess yeah but I guess it makes sense
because obviously you can't make giant
open worlds as an indie Dev it's kind of
tough well maybe you can but it's
obviously a lot harder and making those
other types of games yeah yeah baseball
sense
um yeah I hope they never stop doing
that because I do like that I do and
it's now like every major AAA Studio has
an apology letter on like speed dial it
just seems like every time there's a new
big release uh even though I'm not a
gamer I I for some reason I don't I know
when a game's release when I see the
apology letter because I didn't know
like Star Wars um uh I didn't know the
new Star Wars game was out until I saw
the apology letter and I was like oh
it's out okay I'm actually wanted to
play that for a while
when you when you bought it after the
apology like I I mean wrong with you I I
saw the reviews and I was just there and
they're all like oh there's a frame rate
drop issues and stuff like that and I'm
like I don't care about that God
literally did that I'm not gonna read
this but I'm happy for you all sorry for
your loss you're a monster anyway I'm
like people complaining that Zelda
doesn't run at like 60 frames a second
or something and I'm like what is this
what happened oh it came out honestly
yeah it's like it's like okay I'll take
it oh my God I mean like the only the
only time I don't believe if it is like
a cyberpunk kind of situation and that's
the thing right
um
obviously it's bad that cyberpunk
released in the you know in the
condition that it did with as many bugs
but now that I've played it recently
um now that I've actually waited a year
it's genuinely a [__] great game like
it is a great game yeah I mean
I mean do you think that they should get
as much time as needed and Gamers Gamers
should give them the benefit of the
doubts if they get if like if they end
up actually fixing the bugs with the
games or they're releasing a they just
announced um yeah they just announced a
DLC
oh yeah yeah like see because like this
is an interesting point in contexture
because it's like I the have you seen
the latest naked Jakey video yeah he
made this comparison that I never really
thought about that actually made a lot
of sense of the whole like thing of you
know game comes out that's clearly
unfinished people complain but then when
the game developers fix all the glitches
and bugs and everything with the DLC
then people are like well done well done
for fixing your game and he made this
really cool comparison it's like that's
like if you went to a Taco Bell and you
paid for a full price taco and what you
received at the door was just the taco
shell and some lettuce right but then a
couple weeks later guy comes back and
gives you the rest of the taco and your
reaction is still Applause him he's like
that's exactly the same way that people
are looking at game developers and it's
like it's weird that that's the only way
we kind of view at that point and when
he said that I was like you know what
you kind of make a point why do we react
that way okay okay okay so so I got a
big big opinion all right okay yeah yeah
I did see that video as well yeah and
you know I understood where he was
coming from especially with that analogy
um because yeah I think part of the
reason uh so I'm gonna answer that
question part of the reason I think
people are happy when people fix the
game is because so many game developers
don't go back there's so many EAS out
there that release and unfinished
products and then just leave it like
that and then just never fix it so when
you have those one or two developers
like no man's sky like cyberpunk that
actually come back and actually commit
even though they've already made their
money to fixing the issues uh I do think
that deserves some kind of Praise like
some kind they deserve some kind of
Praise
um my like I guess
I guess my kind of like
to play like that was Advocate to that
kind of argument which is you know why
they're releasing an unfinished product
where which is like cyberpunk
was never ever going to be released in
time at the quality of standards that
people expected yeah and people the
expectations were too high the
expectations were way too high so the
argument is would you wait a year if
because this is what the example I
needed more than a year I mean I mean I
I waited a year and I played it at a you
know when I experienced cyberpunk it was
I've experienced like almost zero bugs
like nothing game breaking nothing it
didn't crash once there was no like game
breaking or immersion breaking glitches
I had I had some bad bugs yeah I was
just dropping through the floor and die
it was like bad yeah damn yeah so I
never experienced like any of that and
that was me waiting like a year to play
cyberpunk because I really wanted to
play cyberpunk and so monk mode I was
like I'll be patient but unfortunately
from what I can see people just aren't
patient you know yeah I I I yeah I
definitely agree people are not because
people always want to play the latest
and best game yeah and unfortunately a
lot of those games do not live up to the
hype yeah and I I was I was talking
about this on stream the other day I was
like I've enjoyed gaming so much more
when I stopped following what games were
being released and I just played a bunch
of games that I thought were interesting
yeah and if the game comes out and it's
amazing people will let you know yeah
yeah like I don't I don't feel any
pressure to play that game immediately
like I I know breath of the Wild's good
the new one I just haven't played it uh
I uh sorry to the kingdom I I know it's
good I don't care about playing it I'll
play it in my own time and I've just
found that I've enjoyed gaming way more
when I've taken that approach yeah uh
it's been more fulfilling because I can
also be like I never expected anything
from any of these games and when they're
good I'm always pleasantly surprised
yeah yeah for sure um so yeah I also I
also said something that I was
controversial and people told me it was
controversial well I hate DLC full stop
I just wish game companies didn't make
DLC
like all kinds of DLC or I am
by the time what's your gaming
philosophy tell me tell me your gaming
because okay because Alden ring is
coming out with a DLC that is crazy big
and it's awesome in Swag yeah
um and I'm sure it's [__] amazing
yeah but I am already done with Alden
ring in my mind yeah right which is a me
this is totally amazing right again yeah
if you want to go back into that world
fantastic
um I wish that they would just instead
of making more for a game that is
already kind of done just to use that
time to make like a second one or
something or make a new ringtone I just
like I know this is a [__] take
um but for me it's like I just don't
want to get reinvest in a DLC
pay like 20 30 bucks for something
when I already feel like I'm kind of out
of it like I'd rather just start
something new no I I actually agree with
that like if the DLC comes out not long
after the like original games came out
like you're still playing the game and
you're still invest in it and a DLC
comes out then I'll be like sweet but if
I if it's like a year or two in between
yeah or like you know even longer
sometimes and I'm just like well yeah
I've kind of already checked out yeah
I'm like two games in to something else
do I really want to jump I I it's it's
probably worth going back in like that's
one of the rare occasions where I feel
like it's worth it but especially when
some of these games split it up into
like four or five DLCs like there's also
a lot of DLCs where I just look at it
I'm like [__] it might look fine but I
just can't be bothered at all it looks
like [__] I want egregious example I
think um Pokemon sword and shield yeah
and that came out with [__] and they're
like no no but the DLC makes is such a
game changer what would have been a game
changer if the game was [__] good
yeah and it was compelling and I mean
no no uh Shield
um oh yeah the two expansions yeah well
we say we're bragging about how amazing
they were foreign
well in my case let's like I already had
beaten the game 100 so I'm like I'm I'm
done with this game like I don't want to
go back I felt I felt burnt I was like
you think I'm a [__] idiot do you
think I'm gonna come crawling back give
you money for the chance that it'll be
good [__] off bro you already took sixty
dollars from me and it sucked that's
like if like an anime was really dog
[__] and they're like no no what's the
OVA yeah it's fine it's fine Joey though
I I have three words to completely throw
a spanner in your argument okay Persona
5 Royal
see
oh my God
I would not count that as a DLC 100
percent of five real why would you not
count it as a DSD also DLC because they
for one the base game they come they
changed so many elements of the story
that it offered a completely new feel to
the story and it actually is I feel you
know what it was I heard the sound deals
for me Persona 5 and I might just be the
only one thing is Persona 5 Royal to me
is not a DLC it's like an HD expansion
uh what's what the [__] is the
difference the expansion is a DLC yeah
no no expansion in the sense of like it
well no because DLC is usually just like
in the case with like sword and shield
right it's like they tack it off to
something that is reimagining yeah it's
like a reimagining basically wait so
it's like a more fleshed out version of
something that is completely different
from the Baseline the question to
somebody who doesn't know either yeah if
I was to jump into the Persona game yeah
which one is the Persona experience
that's why I grew up so it makes percent
of five kind of yeah yeah it does like
that's what I [__] up they bring out a
game that's like oh yeah by the way the
old one [__] useless now yeah it's
it's kind of like
um I mean that's why I brought up
Persona 5 Royal is the argument because
I know you [__] love it
um but I'm like Persona 5 Royal has made
Persona 5 the base game just totally
does it piss you off though you paid
money for Persona 5 and then they like a
year later they were like oh by the way
Persona 5 but better yeah you know what
Atlas take my money
there are two Gamers inside of Joey yeah
one he's the he'll see one loves Persona
5 Royal I hate DLCs if they're not done
by Atlas
I've been doing that since 2010. no they
did it with Persona 4 as well though
yeah yeah they did it without three four
and three and three yeah yeah I mean you
know what every single time the the
reimagined expansion version of it has
always been better yeah but that doesn't
mean that that doesn't that that for me
though that doesn't take away from the
experience of playing the original game
either because I still have great
memories of playing the original Persona
5 when it came out yeah right but now
there's just like an added experience on
top of it yeah I mean I I actually can
agree with you with DLC the way I really
think about it right with something like
Persona 5 uh or like percent five Royale
or a lot of these DLCs is the way I
think about it it's kind of just like
um the Lord of the Rings director's cup
you know do you want the do you want the
three hour director's car and most of
the time I I say no right the most for
most games I don't really care about DLC
I think the only DLC I've actually
bought and enjoyed is the mass effect
DLC and that's my favorite game of all
time you know
um so
you know there is there can be good
content with DLC but most of the time
DLC appeals to me if I haven't played
the game yet you know if I because yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because I
try playing something like the like
Horizon zero Dawn DLCs and the problem
is once you've checked out of the game
once you've completed it and it's been
like [__] months and months DLC yeah
DLC one you don't care two you've
forgotten love it three it's a lot of
time it builds on the base game to be
like post endgame content and by that
point I've already forgotten all the
[__] mechanics you know and the
muscle memory is gone so I'm just
fighting monsters that are like I'm a
beginner uh fighting monsters are like
10 levels above what I remember them
being yeah so I'm like [__] I I've got
to relearn this game just to play the
DLC you know
um and unless the game's simple enough
I'm probably not going to play it and I
agree I would prefer just to get another
base game rather than just I want to
invest myself in like a 30 to 40 hour
a period of like gameplay rather than
just a 10 hour attack on if I hadn't
played the game that's great I get 10
more hours of this extra game that I'm
already invested in yeah um definitely
Case by case for sure yeah I mean I
think the reason it might work for
Royale or something like that is because
it's just a completely finished game you
know yes it's a it's a completely
finished story there is no I mean I say
this but they they did make more pursue
in five just not I don't know what they
did persona for other [__] uh hack
and slash Persona oh [__] I just
realized I made my own argument
irrelevant because that is [__]
you release the tactics game as well
they released the tactics game as well
okay ignore me in a rhythm game I I
don't have an argument to stand on
what's the why the [__] are they so
against putting their things on PC what
are they Atlas yeah it is on PC it is
1005 yes it is yes it is on PC yeah
absolutely recently yes recently why why
recently especially Microsoft because
because game is like you complained loud
no I I wanted it like two years ago yeah
three years ago yeah but you have to
remember as well that like it took 10
years for them to make Persona 5 after
Persona 4. so they are very slow moving
in that sense but in that case you know
what Atlas has very few misses in my
opinion so it's it's worth the wait okay
yeah I'm letting them cook we have I
know Persona 6 has gonna come out in
like 2050 but you know what I'm I'm
gonna let them cook yeah it's gonna be a
good yeah he's here's the thing like
there is not just with games there is
enough media out there to satisfy your
boredom if you don't have something to
play there is enough of a [__]
backlog uh if a game releases if
something like cyberpunk does release in
a buggy form yes of course there is some
fault with the game developers for
releasing that early but a lot of folk
also comes with the company as well for
having uh for setting unrealistic
release schedules well the company is I
mean I I as much as uh uh I'm I'm not
sympathetic towards companies at all
yeah uh but obviously they're just like
all right we have this much money you
gotta this is how long it'll last you've
got to get something out by then and
obviously it's not ready it's like well
we either cut the game or we give more
money or we push it out right now yeah
and uh I mean I think it's just a the
industry is just not in a good spot
right now people are not being paid
enough yep anyway so yeah but the thing
is a lot of these game companies make
like record profits which is like okay
okay so what's the excuse so where's it
going
stop pain and division stop giving your
CEO a 20 million dollar bonus and make a
God [__] good game yeah I mean gamers
are one of the community that I see
complained the most yet somehow they
[__] the most they they keep giving them
money yeah yeah I when I I'm so firmly
against pre-ordering uh I'm a people
pre-ordered [__] I'm like what's wrong
with you you're the reason why we can't
have nice things because they know they
can release this like [__] and you'll
buy it yeah
all right what do you guys think of
Early Access then I hate I hate this
yeah I hate it I know that nobody
advertised it and it's like no they
released it they put it out there people
are gonna play it and they're gonna
they're gonna think that's the game
yeah I don't know yeah yeah I mean to me
Early Access it's like crowdfunding yeah
essentially the way I see it like it's
more of a hey invest in this idea if you
do I promise I'll fix it but there's no
there's no problems to me like Early
Access is cyberpunk's release with
better PR you know I've never really
understood Early Access to me as I
understand it like conceptually on paper
but in practice I'm like well I think it
makes sense like you said conceptually
but I think it it just has been abused
yeah a lot of people you know especially
in like horror games they'll just make a
half-baked horror game breaking a bunch
of money getting that Pat video and then
they're like all right
I don't like it anymore
it's got a good old map pack keeping
Early Access horror games alive
geez like it's like you look at
something like Poppy's play time and
like you're in I wasn't like Fuji q and
they were selling uh
yeah they were selling [__] poppy
playtime plushies in fujiku I'm like
what the [__] is this game that big yeah
what the hell oh I thought about I
thought that the first time I saw Five
Nights at Freddy's as well and you could
just like buy Freddy Fazbear plushies
uh Five Nights at Freddy's movie no
there's the making a movie there's a
trailer there's a trailer it looks like
it looks decent really it looks like
shut the [__] up get the [__] out
I haven't seen it up
get the [__] out of here it doesn't look
like I imagined some you know something
map make a video out of five nights of
Freddy official is this just the
official
teaser's Pizzeria we're fantasy okay fun
come to life hit it guys
if you're watching this video
it means you've been selected as
Freddy's newest security guard
looks like a parody it is
we're going to have so much fun together
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up
ain't no way that's gonna it didn't look
as bad
do you know do you know what that
reminded me of you know when you know
somewhat you log into YouTube someday
and someone made a parody like of a
different type of genre of uh like
Pokemon or some [__] yeah so that's
that's yeah it's like Pokemon if it was
a hobby yeah yeah
wasn't there a Nicolas Cage film that
was basically like Five Nights at
Freddy's what was it called yeah there
was there was a Nicholas Cage film that
was like six nights at Sarah's it was
like four nights at Chuckies
yeah I think it was uh very uh it's I
mean obviously they don't own the
concept of a kids animatronic dance yeah
where is Wonderland he's actually like I
heard it was pretty weird I mean all
Nicholas he doesn't he doesn't speak in
the film yeah there is no battle no
that's why it's good no there is no bad
Nicholas Cage film you cannot you cannot
convince me that there is a bad necklace
I don't think he even realized he's
acting
I don't think he realized this camera's
running yeah I don't actually think he
knows what happened I think he's just
turns up and they pay him
he's a character in the uh what's that
part
[Music]
yeah he he is my his model like him as
an actor is actually right
oh really
CFT
but no do you you know what I talked
about earlier about how memes have
ruined certain pieces of media memes
have already ruined this film for me
even if it's good you know one of the
Mungus movies
it's gonna happen it's uh guarantee he
said he was sauce if this is is the if
this is legitimately happening and it
does well they're going to make it among
us they're going to have an Among Us
movie and then it's gonna it's gonna end
with yeah I think
[Music]
[Laughter]
is that if something is memed enough
it's actually going to be made I think
again I could be wrong I think Poppy's
play time they were trying to make
something like an animated thing or
something oh my God right even though
it's oh God
have you played it ah have you played it
no I've played both parts I've seen I've
seen playthroughs of it it's it's awful
yeah it just looks like Walmart Five
Nights Freddy's oh yeah it's it's it's
terrible yeah so bad it's not good at
all it's so popular it was popular I
think it's fallen off quite a bit oh
really yeah because it's every as a
flavor of the week horror that always
replaces it yeah there's some other game
that came out that was like a terrible
version of that which is saying
something
um there's only there's always another
game that's being released there's
always some kind of like hot indie
horror game right yeah is there because
I haven't I haven't heard of much
recently because I like I think if you
don't follow the circles probably
because of that but like I mean I
remember you know it seemed like it felt
like it peaked for me during like the
PewDiePie screamo era you know the uh
no there's way more like the Five Nights
at Freddy's the the size
it was ridiculous I mean yeah it the the
even if you don't care for it which I
don't there were entire channels I
remember back in there like 2015 2016
they were just purely dedicated to Five
Nights theory was getting like 10
million views of videos yeah which is
crazy exactly for that like it was it
was Finance really was absolutely
massive yeah yeah and on a scale that I
think we haven't seen on YouTube before
um way more than amnesia yeah yeah yeah
I'm usually as a game was never really
popular but Amnesia is like a YouTube
content was always pretty I mean there
are some games that exist out there that
I'm like this would not exist if
YouTubers and twitch streamers weren't a
thing you know Happy Wheels you remember
that [__] game
this is fun happy wheels is fun but I
feel it wouldn't have gotten as popular
if it wasn't for the YouTubers playing
it oh for sure yeah jump King right
corner all right I would have been very
far for that it's a great game Pogo
stalker would not have been better oh
God for a lot of these YouTube videos
get uh for for a lot of the indie horror
games getting a YouTube video explaining
your lore blow up is uh I mean that's
that's uh best marketing strategy oh
yeah I mean look at fear and hunger yeah
that's a great example of that right
groups love crazy games with interesting
Concepts yeah do you know what thought I
had recently oh God while we're on the
topic of what we think the future is
going to be go on do you think food has
peaked
do you think do you think cooking
okay okay let me explain myself let me
explain myself okay okay okay this is
this is gone going into like Widow
shower thoughts mode this is like you
you think that's pretty well like
British people thought when they like
discovered curry
spice fruits Peak guys yeah like do you
think you've tasted the best thing
you've you're ever going to taste in
your life already no uh I've gotten
close I'd say
what do you mean I got close for for a
video uh I got served Sushi from the
best sushi chef in the world right um
using the best fish in the world and
that one piece of tuna that I had fatty
yeah was like the closest I've ever
gotten to coming in my pants while
eating like legitimately I I I think in
terms of in terms of food in general no
I don't think I've had the best thing in
terms of seafood yes I think I have had
it well I think maybe the ingredients
well it's always changing right because
like think about like you're gonna say
Russell Sprouts is that we're gonna say
yeah I mean I was gonna say brussels
sprouts you know they always find you
know I'm like remember when we like grew
up we like it was like a meme that you'd
never eat the Brussels sprouts
I always like them see I [__] hated
them and then suddenly over like the
past 10 years it almost felt like people
just figured out how to cook them yeah
like you know I think genetically
they've changed oh really yeah right
they're actually like even genetic not
as better anymore yeah I I can't
remember could you Google this
um I I think that something's changed
genetically and now they're a lot more
appetizing yeah and and obviously people
have gotten better at cooking them yeah
I think that goes hand at hand with like
when they taste better people get better
at cooking them because they want to use
them more yeah that's why like whenever
we're in the US and I see Brussels and
Sprouts of the menu I'm like we're
ordering these yeah I know they're going
to be bombed they're always so good if
they have the audacity to report it on a
menu oh you know every time every time
Hawaii we ate them they were so they
were always looking good yeah yeah sure
because like okay I don't know I don't
know if I've I don't I don't know if
this is just something like worldwide or
just something that I've noticed in my
very very small circles but do you think
people have just gotten better at
cooking periods yeah of course because
knowledge is more accessible and we have
tools in the kitchen that that allow you
to cook experiment more yeah you know
like rice rice cookers a great way of
getting perfect rice why people discover
how to properly cook rice because of
because of Uncle Roger I I don't think
I'd ever had rice that was cooked
properly in my entire life to like him
to Japan really yeah because I'll
probably use [__] sifting it through
a column I was taught to sift it yeah so
like that and then also you know just
technology getting better like
appliances getting better methods of
cooking getting like you know like we
have the airfryer now like stuff like
yeah I think they'll always be something
and then obviously
we're always playing God and genetically
modifying our Foods yeah to make them
taste better so I think I think it'll
always get better and then we're
eventually going to get to that point
like in all the post-apocalyptic movies
where it's just like a one and all like
a one and all I mean I don't think we'll
ever get to that point because people
yeah I'm kind of doing that now I feel
like it's already there almost I drink
like there's meal replacements sometimes
when I'm streaming so I can't be
bothered to order food and I go I don't
know and it's so sad because I I'm kind
of like mourning the death of food yeah
you're like the one person who like food
I love food so much it's so sad that I
have to drink this thing I don't have to
but uh you're opting to yeah because
it's just easy yeah it's great though
food's so great but I don't want to
[__] I've seen him it's not like
grind go on on stream just was like hey
guys I'm gonna be out be right back in
an hour I'm gonna go eat lunch I just I
just left his stream for an hour to go
eat lunch and I'm like mad respect to
you I don't know why I'm in my brain I
can't and don't want to do that and I'm
like I just want to keep doing the thing
yeah no because I'm I mean I value
getting a lunch I I value enjoying my
meal and just having a me time uh I'm
actually watching the news the dude's
like all right well there is more news
uh but I'm gonna head out for lunch so
I'll see you guys now okay here's here's
the thing though okay um I mean I have
the privilege of doing this because
streaming isn't my you know main job I
kind of see it as a hobby but like if
I'm live I don't want to eat lunch and I
want to enjoy my lunch uh any other
office employee can be like all right
I'm going out for a lunch break What I
Call On streamers do this you know it's
that's I I just went I just went on my
lunch break why is that why is that why
is that such a [__] like like awful
thought in the world of streaming I
think well I think it's because like you
know unlike at an office job you don't
have a bunch of people coming to you
like waiting to see what you're doing
you know that's like if you're out of
[__] football stadium and the Umpire
was like so I know we're in the middle
of a game uh 30 000 people in the state
medium but uh I really need to go get a
snack so I'm gonna hold the game right
now the games actually I was like the
game's like going for eight hours maybe
maybe some sports too okay but you don't
stream five days a week you know [__]
there are some little joys in life that
I that I think people all people should
have and a lunch break and a nice dinner
is just one of those things you know I
just would have loved him in a view in
their stream like [__] enjoying every
moment yeah what was Chad doing the
entire time and you're like all right
I'm going out no because I've I've
literally been on stream and I'm like
sure I forgot I had a meeting now uh
I'll be back in an hour and I'll just
put it on like be right back
okay I've done that yeah I've done that
that's funny I don't know I'm just like
if you know streamers are so it it
always seems like they're just addicted
to streaming and I'm like a part of it
is just having kind of have to be yeah
part of it yeah I mean it's not that I'm
addicted it's that I want to provide the
best viewer experience and me not
disappearing for an hour as part of that
yeah but I mean come on
no I mean like I mean I don't know man
you've done sleeping streams yeah yeah I
I mean I think and enjoyed guys let me
go to sleep yeah an important thing is
having a healthy lifestyle around that
and I'm like which is like level
impossible for a lot of streams and also
I just don't really care so I I do this
as a hobby so I'm like if I want my
lunch break I'm I'm jealous I respected
I wish I had that mindset you should try
it once yeah you should be like what the
[__] just to see how they respond yeah
but uh I guess I guess like well what
are we talking about yeah the thing is
about food I was just like there's been
a few moments in my life where you
remember that first time you've tried
this new dish that has not reached any
flavor profile that you've like had
previously yeah and it's just like you
know I remember like the first time had
like A5 wagyu and first time obviously
it was like holy [__] this is God life
um I've never tasted like this at so I
don't have something to
compare this to my previous experience
because nothing has tasted like this
thing I'm tasting and I'm like have I
have I is is am I ever going to
experience that again you know it's have
have I tasted everything that there is
possibly to taste that's going to taste
good you know because like you know I'm
sure there's things I haven't tasted
well unless you've traveled to every
single country in the world with every
single different food culture in the
world I don't think you'll ever get to
that point yeah honest you know like not
everything you're going to have is gonna
be the most like orgasm-inducing thing
like A5 wagyu but like you're probably
gonna you know if you travel the world
and you see all sorts of different food
cultures there's probably gonna be one
item in the hundreds of thousands where
you're like holy [__] why is no one
talking about this yeah it's just I
realize Japan like sport me because when
I moved to Japan that was just one year
of just like every month I'm like holy
[__] this is amazing holy [__] fatty
tuna all right A5 wagyu unagi uh uh soup
curry oh my God that was that was such a
magical year and I'm like chasing that
high again man I'm just chasing that
high it's never gonna happen enjoy what
you have enjoy what you have what you
love it I'm not saying I don't I don't
like good food anymore it's just I think
Japan has just ruined your perception of
the peak of food yeah
I'm like I'm like now nowadays I'm like
maybe food's Peaks yeah I don't know I
don't know I don't know maybe I've
piqued my food experience I'm never
gonna really get this food peaked
well that's the thing that's the thing
right can you know you know we've been
to you know I'm sure Merlin has taken us
to some like Michelin stuff like a
restaurant and to me it's never lived up
to the price point or it's never even
come close to being like the best thing
I've tasted and that's true for like
most Michelin star places uh the thing I
hate most about Michelin star places and
it's always the fancy places that do
this single worst dishes in the food
existence it's just foam there's an
obsession with foam in like rich places
like meringue and [__] no no like just
foam they'll be like we've turned this
fish into a phone and it's delightful
and you try it you're like it tastes
like a fish coming in my mouth I'm like
I don't want this like you have had this
we've been to restaurants where where
which one um they have some Bloom with
all one no not that one um there's just
in Japan they do it a lot I went to one
the other day and they had like unagi
foam and I thought [__] hell what the
[__] yeah I was like this tastes like
ass I don't want this then there I went
to when we went to that Sukiyaki place
oh yeah it was one where melene took us
too and it was like it was an egg it was
egg foam you would dunk it in and it was
gross because it tastes like again it
was like foam it's like I hate foam it's
not foaming [__] just give me a liquid
or a solid God damn it yeah so that's my
rant on foam yeah so to me I hate the
word deconstructed if there is if there
is something Deconstructed on the menu I
already know I I'd rather just have the
thing that is deconstructing it's a
Lunchable deconstruction
that's basically what deconstructed is
we're taking a plastic wrap it's just
very fancy Lunchables that's what that's
what you've done here isn't Mr chair
like fajitas deconstructed tacos kind of
nice uh kind of I mean
it's just a hamburger [__] so let's just
hamburger wait hold on hold on hold on
hold on let him cook
yeah I don't know I I like features
though fajitas I [__] love her yes it
is great yeah
I like it because of the control you
know the control of how you can make the
fajita the way you want to make your
fajita you know I mean the weakness of
fajita is that you you are the one
making it there too because you're like
you're like you've had three fajitas in
you're like this is great and then
you're like wait I have two tortillas
left and way too much
but all the other way around that's not
your problem that's the portion size
problem you know you'd never get this
problem in America because you'd you'd
have or sometimes you you share with
someone and they put way too much in
their fajita you're like you gotta calm
down we are sharing this so that's the
problem is you put two worth of fajitas
in one yeah you've got to stop that
right now yes we I am not rationing this
but that's the problem with fajitas
right like you said you like the control
of it right but it's like it's you're
not in control because the put the
portion sizes that they give you are
already like preset well unless you're
not actually in control you're just like
you're in a you're in a pre-rendered cut
scene
and that should spilling out everywhere
I'm like
I'm like you're doing it wrong you're
doing it wrong
yeah I've just realized why is this just
like a scientific fact where when you
order fajita you will always get less
like you would always get less Meats
than there is
I like fajita Patties or like because
it's cheaper for them
they're cutting the corners bro but
anyway I guess that was our food future
as food Peaks a view of the future all
that fun stuff and think of this in the
trash hey but look at all these patrons
though and I'm sure I can see the future
of all of you who haven't joined the
patreon yet that you will join the
patreon if you love the show and would
like to hear more of our rambling and
you know what you can do that by going
to patreon.com trash taste you can also
uh follow us on the subreddit uh send us
your memes on the Twitter or the
subreddit and uh if you hate our face
listen to us on Spotify all right well
thank you for watching this episode of
trash taste we'll see you in the future
all right
foreign
[Music]